es ist der neueste trend verwandtschaft
bestimmung von wem stammt eigentlich ab
und wie viele meiner verwandten kenne
ich wirklich das ganze per dna oma opa
tante und onkel aber bei den
urgroßeltern da hört es schon auf ein
forschungsteam aus den usa hat jetzt den
größten stammbaum der welt erstellt und
demnach sind 13 millionen menschen über
500 jahre miteinander verbundene eine
art super familie und das finde ich
absolut krass ihr habt euch dieses thema
bei whatsapp gewünscht und bekommt jetzt
alles spannenden effekt dazu herzlich
willkommen bei pixum science fiction
tausend dank für den sensationellen
themenvorschlag
ja wie gesagt einen themenvorschlag über
whatsapp vielen dank dafür
und wie er da dabei sein könnt und
themen vorschlagen können und vor allem
die unzuverlässige abo box von youtube
weil ist das erfahrt ihr am ende des
videos und 86 millionen personenprofile
die hauptsächlich von hobby
ahnenforscher rinnen und forschern
angelegt worden waren
die sind in die hinter untersuchung des
us amerikanischen forschungsteams
eingeflossen
daraus entstanden ist tatsächlich der
größte stammbaum der welt er verbindet
13 millionen menschen über elf
generationen miteinander
das sind mehr familienmitglieder als
belgien einwohner hat und solche
stammbäume verraten unfassbar viel über
uns menschen und die welt in der wir
leben beispielsweise spiegelt der
riesige welt stammbaum solche ereignisse
wider wie die besiedlung nordamerikas
durch die europäer ebenso wie die
kolonialisierung afrikas zudem zeigt die
aktuelle studie aber spannender weise
auch das auch im 19 jahrhundert lange
noch innerhalb der familie geheiratet
wurde nachvollziehbar auch der fakt dass
die menschen in der studie waren es vor
allem amerikaner vor 1750 ihre partner
in einem umkreis von etwa zehn kilometer
fanden diejenigen die erst 1959 geboren
worden waren bewegten sich schon im
umkreis von 100 kilometern
durchschnittlich um die liebe ihres
lebens zu finden
das us-amerikanische forschungsteam
fanden in der untersuchung aus dass gute
gene keinesfalls entscheidend für ein
langes leben sind bisher dachte man ja
dass das erbgut zu bis zu 30 prozent für
ein langes leben verantwortlich ist doch
die analyse legt nahe dass dies nur in
16 prozent der fälle entscheidend ist im
durchschnitt könnten gute gene ein leben
um bis zu fünf jahre verlängern
im vergleich dazu haben andere studien
gezeigt dass rauch und zum beispiel zehn
jahre an lebenszeit kosten kann heißt
also im klartext solch einer
entscheidung im leben beispielsweise zu
rauchen fällt demnach mehr ins gewicht
als gute gene
das nur als kleiner fun fact am randen
doch es gibt immer mal wieder studien
die zeigen dass wir doch enger
miteinander verwandt sind als wir
glauben so eine us studie aus dem jahr
2013 in der die dna von 2500 menschen
analysiert wurde demnach stamm setzen
selbst menschen die durch einen
kontinent voneinander getrennt sind von
denselben
vorfahren ab und die wiederum lebten
erst vor 1000 jahren und da sind jetzt
nicht unendlich viele generationen für
die menschheitsgeschichte ist das
tatsächlich nur ein sehr kleiner
zeitraum das forschungsteam suchte nach
dna abschnitten die an den nachkommen
nahezu unverändert in einem größeren
block weitergegeben worden waren
an der länge der gemeinsamen blöcke ließ
sich also dann ablesen wie lange der
letzte gemeinsame vorfahre von zwei
menschen zurückliegt dazu einer der
beteiligten forscher gramkow
bemerkenswert ist wie in jeder mit jedem
verwandt ist auf genial logischer ebene
geht jeder mensch in europa auf fast den
gleichen satz von vor 1000 jahren
lebenden vorfahren zurück wie jeder
andere abgesehen von solchen
wissenschaftlichen untersuchungen gibt
es im netz viele möglichkeiten um seinen
eigenen stammbaum zu generieren in
diversen online datenbanken können
stammbäume geteilt und miteinander
verbunden werden zudem werden auch dna
tests angeboten ich hatte am anfang
erwähnt und der abgleich mit anderen
profilen soll dann auskunft über den
eigenen ursprung geben dass das
forschungsteam genau solch eine
öffentliche online datenbank genutzt hat
die hauptsächlich von laien angelegt
worden war übrigens ein gutes beispiel
dafür dass citizen science also bürger
wissenschaft von großem nutzen sein kann
wenn sie entsprechend verantwortungsvoll
gemacht wird wenn ihr nichts zu diesem
thema und zu allen anderen themen
verpassen wollt dann endet mich bei
whatsapp und den anderen messengern je
nachdem welchen er wollte nur dann
verpasst ihr kein video denn die abo box
auf youtube die ist ja meistens ziemlich
unvollständig nur mit seinem messenger
abo erfahrt ihr von mir vor allen
anderen vom neuesten video täglich
garantiert einfach hier draufklicken und
zur begrüßung habe ich ein kleines
goodie und am besten auch meinen
schwesterkanal klicks um social media
abonnieren darf hat er das neueste aus
der social media welt nicht die genaue
vergessen und hier geht es weiter mit
dafür auch draufklicken unglaubliches
bio hecking bakterien infizieren
computer ansonsten bis dann bleibt dran